All right. People. This is the Rubin report. Direct message.
I'm still Dave Rubin and we are just days out from the big election.
Can you believe it just days out from the very day that will decide the
future of humanity? We're almost there guys. I voted yesterday.
That's going to be one of our stories.
I didn't even have to show my ID was really wonderful.
I would have to show my ID to buy a beer. Uh, even though I'm 44 years old,
I still get Aidid, but you don't have to show your ID to vote.
So we're going to talk about that. We are going to talk about, uh,
measure 16 here in California, where, uh,
the progressives,
the wonderful lefties are putting racism back into the system and we got to
vote on it. So I voted on it. I'll show you what I decided on,
whether I wanted the country to be more racist or less racist,
and we'll read the exact text. And, uh, you know,
if you don't have systemic racism in the system,
which we don't here in the United States, there are no racist laws, uh,
the best way to get systemic racism.
So you can use it to fuel the fire of burning.
Everything down that you're trying to do is to put it on the ballot,
especially here in California. Cause these people are idiots. Uh,
so we're going to cover that. Uh, then we're going to talk about, uh,
coronavirus deaths because they are dropping. Believe it or not,
the media seems to be pushing this notion that they're, they're growing again,
everything's going up and up and up.
It's a little hard to decipher some of the information because obviously as we
test more, we see more rising cases.
This is where Trump always gets lost in language because people say, well,
if we, he always says, well, if we weren't testing,
we wouldn't see the numbers going up. And people are like, no,
the numbers would still go up. You're both kind of correct. Uh,
if we weren't testing, that means, uh, numbers could be going up or down.
We wouldn't know. So the more you test,
the more you're going to see that the numbers are going up in case if in fact
they are going up. Uh, but in essence,
there is a new study that is confirming the fact that
deaths are dropping despite cases rising.
So we'll get into some of the numbers. I hope you brought your calculator.
And then the third story for today is that big tech hearing yesterday. Uh,
I focus mostly on Jack Dorsey yesterday and the fact that he basically
lied under oath, Ted Cruz, and could be in a lot of trouble for doing that.
And you guys know all the,
all the stuff about big tech censorship and the rest of it,
but then something really interesting happened where Mark Zuckerberg,
who of course is the synthetic humanoid that's in charge of, uh, Facebook. Uh,
he did not know apparently that the head of election integrity
at, uh, Facebook, you still work for, you're not going to believe it guys,
Joe, by can. I know it's so weird. It's just, it's just so weird.
So we're going to get into all that I'm feeling good today.
I'm highly caffeinated. I put on a jacket for you.
And before we do anything else, guys, I want to talk to you about built bar.
Are you guys looking for a new protein bar that tastes like a candy bar?
I've got just the brand for you.
Built bars are super tasty and come in 18 amazing flavors. My personal favorite,
as you know already is the cookies and cream that I've got right here,
but we've got a box filled with all kinds and I've been trying them.
And they're good people. Bill bars are covered in a hundred percent.
Chocolate include both nut and nut free flavors and are soft and easy to chew
with Halloween just days away. It's easy to slip up,
which is why bill bars are the perfect alternative to candy for the health
conscious guy.
I can actually lose or maintain weight while indulging in a delicious treat,
built bars or low calorie, low sugar, high protein, and high fiber.
I'm not making it up guys. Then the six pack quite there yet, but we're,
we're getting close.
Go to belt bar.com and use promo code Rubin and you'll get 20% off your first
order.
Use promo code Rubin 20% off your first order@billbarr.com.
Good for bill BARR is built, go or bill boost. And now back to me,
hello. All right. So I voted yesterday, guys. I early voted,
uh, David and I went to our local polling station.
We brought our IDs. We brought some documentation showing where we live,
the whole thing we got in the car. Our, we went in and we voted,
we did not have to show IDs. We did not have to show any identification.
I did not realize that. I actually didn't realize that.
I remember that during the primaries where I did vote,
that I didn't need anything. And I thought that was a little bizarre.
And I know there's always this ongoing thing about voter ID,
but I thought surely at the national election,
someone's going to check something right? Like that. You can't just walk in.
Just say you are whoever you are and know someone's address and vote as them.
But that is literally what you can do here in the banana Republic of California.
So I said my name and I said, my address,
I did not show any evidence that I am me or that I live in that place.
And then I went up to the machine and it was electronic and touch pad and the
whole thing. And I, and I did my thing, but quite literally, and,
and I don't want people to feel that the election is illegitimate.
Obviously you don't want to,
but we do have to secure our elections at some level,
the idea that you don't have to show an ID. So I could actually go back.
I could get in my car right now. And in eight minutes,
be at my polling station again. And assuming that they didn't know who I was,
I could say, yeah, I'm Bob, blah, blah, blah. And I live at do-do to do,
and then I could vote as Bob and then Bob could show up and I guess Bob would be
screwed. I mean, the idea, let's just be very, very clear on this.
The only people who don't want voter ideal ID laws are the people who are for
voter fraud. Okay? Everyone can get an ID. You need an ID to buy a beer.
You need an ID to drive a car. You need an ID to get on a plane.
But for some reason, if we say to people, you need an ID to vote,
which is your most important civic duty. Somehow that's construed as racist,
right? It's racist,
or you don't want poor people to vote or something like that.
Everyone can get an ID. Virtually everyone has an ID. It's offensive.
If you were to say, well, black people don't have IDs. What you talking about?
Your racists, you guys realize that you guys are the racist.
You call everybody racist, but you're the actual racist.
I have plenty of black friends. They all have IDs.
I fairly certain I know who they all are. Uh, the whole thing is so stupid. Um,
but so the idea that you can do, this is kind cool, crazy. Uh,
but let's talk about who I voted for. And,
and one of the measures that I voted, yes, we,
we can throw up the image because it's out there already. I did vote for
Donald J. Trump and Michael R Pence. Those are the people that I voted for.
Uh, I've been telling you guys for probably about four months,
that was the direction I was headed in. Uh,
right before I went off the grid for August. I did Kyle coz shoots podcast.
And he flat out asked me who I was going to vote for.
And I hadn't said it publicly yet, but obviously I've been thinking this for,
for many, many months at this point, uh, that, that Trump was the right choice.
Do I think Trump is perfect. Let's do all the asks stuff first.
Do I think Trump is perfect? I don't do.
Sometimes he tweeted less. I do.
Is there something kind of funny about his hair? Yes. It's cetera, et cetera.
But has he basically done a good job as president?
Let let's put Corona virus aside for one second, I will address it, uh,
in just a moment in our whole second story is about Corona before Corona,
did we have an absolutely thriving economy, which by the way, today,
we're getting some numbers that are really, really good on the,
on the rebound we did. And we had all time, low black unemployment, right?
An all time low, uh, Latino unemployment. Absolutely. Uh, yeah.
Peace in the middle East thing.
Israel signing all of these deals with middle East countries. That's good.
That's good. We all used to want middle East peace now, orange man,
we don't want it so much anymore. Uh,
the changing of some of these crazy international deals that we had,
like the Paris climate Accords,
that was a non-binding deal that in effect we were paying for,
and now we're out of, and by the way, uh,
I've read and you guys can find the articles yourself. In many cases were,
we're actually exceeding some of the numbers that were dictated to us by the
power of climates, but by the Paris climate Accords, this is a good thing.
Getting rid of regulation, lowering taxes, all of these things are good.
Oh, and I forgot the big two taking critical race theory out of the
universities and out of our federal institutions.
This is beyond massive. If you hate identity, did he politics?
If you love America, if you believe people should be treated as individuals,
Trump,
Trump had the most intense death blow to the,
those bads set of ideas.
When he said the government will not Institute these ideas, um,
this is huge. So he got critical race theory out. He also reversed title IX.
Title IX was the Obama executive action that in essence took away due
process. So if a male student, it did a few things,
but one of them that was used quite frequently was that if a male student was
accused of sexual harassment, basically you didn't,
you could be kicked out of college just by the accusation.
And we removed due process. Well, Trump got rid of that.
When he brought in Betsy Devoss as education secretary, there,
there is a series of good things he's done. Um,
but all of those things combined,
I would still say even maybe the bigger thing is that he has fought the media.
He has fought the establishment and,
and no other Republican was going to do it. And, and, you know, yeah,
you might go that McCain guy was nicer and that Romney guy was nicer and
whatever it is, those guys,
the lost Trump has mapped out a way for right-leaning people, conservatives,
disaffected liberals, libertarians to fight the machine.
And that was, that was worthy of my vote. It doesn't mean he's perfect.
And I have no doubt that I'm going to have more hit pieces written about me and
that the rest of the, the anger and the hate will come. But as I often say,
I am my own boss. And the chances that I fire myself are pretty slim,
I suppose it could happen one day. Um, so that, that is who I voted for.
I voted for Trump. I was actually very happy to vote for Trump.
And I know again, I'm going to have, I'm going to have not only hippies,
but I know people in my life are not going to be happy with me. But, um,
you know, when I was off the grid, I watched this, uh,
Frank Sinatra documentary on Netflix. It's a,
two-part about two hours each documentary on Frank Sinatra.
And I love Frank Sinatra and the old crooners and the rat pack and all that.
But there's a moment where he's talking about elections and voting and things
like that. And he was very politically active as a Democrat at first.
And then eventually he became friends with Ronald Reagan who became the
Republican governor of California and obviously ultimately president.
And he started the media, started turning on him.
Frank Sinatra was like a darling of the media when he was a Democrat.
And then you're not going to believe it.
This stuff has obviously gone on for decades when he started becoming a little
more conservative or at least supporting a California conservative Ronald
Reagan, the media started going after him and he gave this,
you should watch it in the documentary.
There's just this couple of lines on just how it's your duty as a man to,
to do what you think is right and vote for the people you think is right.
And you have to do that and don't let people cower you and scare you into doing
what they want. So I hope I hope if you're on the fence right now,
whichever way you're going to go,
that you do what your conscience tells you to do.
And now with the mob tells you to do, I think that's,
that's the most important thing that you can do. So anyway,
so I voted for Trump and I didn't have to show my ID.
So tomorrow I'll vote for Trump. Again, it's very, very exciting. And, uh,
and now I want to shift a little bit to, to measure 16 because you know,
when you vote, uh, there's all sorts of people you can vote for. I also,
by the way, I voted for Eric early, who is running against Adam shift, that,
that Russia collusion maniac. Uh, so I voted for Eric early.
Who's a Republican running against him.
I also voted basically no on all of the measures because everything increases
taxes, sorry, state, you can't have any more money from the people.
You don't deserve any of it. There might've been one or two exceptions to that.
Um, but basically I voted no on all of those things. And I voted, you know,
I tried to figure out who were the least lefty people though in this state,
it's pretty bananas. Um, but do vote on several measures.
And I want to talk about measure 16 specifically. So let's,
let's throw the image up there.
And I'm going to read to you a little bit about what measures 16 is.
It will allow diversity as a factor in public employment,
education and contracting decisions,
legislative constitutional amendment, just to be very clear.
It will allow diversity as a factor in public employment,
education and contracting decisions,
meaning they will care about your skin color, your gender and your sexuality.
The stuff that we did, the 64 civil rights act to get rid of.
We shouldn't care about those things. Martin Luther King,
we're not going to care about the color of your skin.
That's what he didn't want for his kids.
He wanted them to care about the content of their character, uh,
but not here in California, apparently.
And I'll just read two parts of this thing. Uh,
this proposition would permit the government permits government decision-making
policies to consider race, sex, color, ethnicity,
or national origin to address diversity by repealing article one,
section 30, one of the California constitution.
So we are amending the constitution to put systemic racism into it,
which was added by proposition two Oh nine in 1996.
Okay. You got that people. So 24 years ago, we said,
let's get discrimination out. Now we're going to vote it back in apparently, uh,
proposition two Oh nine,
generally prohibit state and local governments from discriminating against or
granting preferential treatment to individuals or groups on the basis of race,
sex, color, ethnicity,
or national origin in the operation of public employment education.
That's the good one. You morons. That's the one, two Oh nine.
We wrap this thing up in 96. Okay.
That's the good one prohibits state and local governments from discriminating
against or granting preferential treatment to individuals on the basis of race
sex. I read it already. I circled it here.
I put a box over the circle. What is wrong with you people?
So we are literally right now in California voting to put racism,
voting, to put discrimination, voting,
to put bigotry back into the system. And let me just try this this way.
If you are one of the people who thinks, Oh, but we do want more diversity.
Well, I understand that. That's a nice thought to have, uh,
now think about it this way.
Would you be for discriminating against someone based on their
skin, color, sexuality, gender, or anything else? Ah,
gotcha. Denied. Because if you elevate somebody because of those things,
you have to D boost to use their language, somebody because of those things.
So this is nonsensical. It is psychotic. I'm barely,
certainly it's against the constitution of the United States.
And this is the type of thing that could end up as a Supreme court decision. Um,
so good luck with that, Amy Coney Barrett. Um, but it's, it's just,
it's just ridiculousness. I wonder if this is happening in any other States,
can you guys let me know,
throw some comments in there if you see this happening anywhere besides
California, this Looney Looney place. Oh,
and before we move on to the next story, I should mention that, uh,
the president, you know, this guy, Trump, um,
I was on Fox and friends this morning. I was up at 4:00 AM for like a five 15,
uh, Fox and friends appearance. And then I went to sleep.
I basically was on at five 15 till about five 20.
Then I tried to go to sleep for about two hours. I woke up, my phone was hot,
you know, when you know, it'd be like, your phone's going crazy. And it's like,
you got like a nuclear device in your hand and you just throw this thing and
it's going to explode. Um, well, Trump tweeted this about me.
We'll throw it up there. Uh, thank you to Dave Rubin author of don't burn.
This book just announced on Fox and friends that he is voting for your favorite
president. Me, I think Donald Trump has done a lot of good.
What I see in American flag. I see Trump's support. Well,
I just laid out there. Why I think that our vote, excuse me, why?
I think a vote for Trump is, is sensible and is good and is fair.
And it doesn't make you a racist or a bigot or anything else. Um, but you got,
this is like one of those things where it's like the way he writes these things,
it's like voting for your favorite president. Me,
there's no business like show business like that.
That's kind of where we're at at this point. Um, in any event, it was,
it was nice to see that I already got some people texting me that are,
that are angry at me because the president tweeted at me. I, you know,
in the old days, if the president said something nice about you,
people would support you. So it's a little bit of a strange thing these days.
Um, okay. Let's, let's talk about coronavirus because obviously there are,
there are critics of Trump and people who won't vote for Trump because of
coronavirus. Um, so I wanted to hold this to the,
to the second story that we're doing right now. Let's,
let's throw the graph up there. Uh,
so NPR and there, you know,
these are not people that like Trump studies point to big drop in COVID-19 death
rates. Uh, this is updated as a few days ago.
I'm just going to read a little bit too.
New peer reviewed studies are showing a sharp drop in mortality,
amongst hop hospitalized. COVID-19 patients.
The drop is seen in all groups, including older patients,
and those with underlying conditions suggesting that physicians are getting
better at helping patients survive their illness.
Mortality has dropped amongst hospitalized patients by 18
percentage points. Since the pandemic began,
the people who are getting hospitalized now tend to be much younger,
tend to have fewer other diseases and tend to be less frail than people who were
hospitalized in the early days of the epidemic. Okay.
I wanted to do this story because this is showing you that we're rounding the
corner. We flatten the curve where we're rounding the corner.
Other assorted statement that doesn't really explain what's going on.
These are good things, right?
These are good things you would report on spiraling death tolls.
If you want it to show the truth,
but if you really want to do it just to get Trump,
then you're not going to show this.
So my guess is CNN is not going to be doing much on this today, right?
The New York times, ain't going to be doing much on this today. Um,
but the simple truth is the doctors are dealing with it better.
We're seeing less older people die.
We also know that younger people that get the disease, they survive.
As I said a few weeks ago, I know a few people that have gotten coronavirus.
They were sick for a few days. One of my friends was sick for about 10 days,
but most were sick for two or three days.
I have a friend that got it that had no symptoms whatsoever, um,
that you will get past it and you will survive the idea that we have decided
to shut down the entire country destroy people's livelihoods.
As I said yesterday, now we know that alcoholism is rising. Suicide is rising.
People are not getting out. They're not exercising.
They're not seeing other human beings.
We're spending all our days like automated, robotic human autonomy.
Um, I mean, it's, it's just we've we made a mistake along the way.
And where are all of the people?
Where are the freedom loving people saying it's time to move forward. And,
and just imagine,
just imagine if Biden gets in charge and the Democrats are in
charge, Biden wants a federal lockdown.
You want to just keep giving these people more power over you.
Gavin Newsome cannot tell me what I can do for Thanksgiving.
I'm going to do whatever the hell I want to do. You can.
I'm telling you directly right now, Gavin Newsome.
I'm gonna have as many people as I want,
and we're gonna do whatever the hell we want. And that might include singing,
which I know you don't want people to sing your freak. Um, so anyway,
it's important to know that the numbers are going down in terms of mortality.
People are not dying. As much people are getting better and,
and just know that and, and take,
and of course take whatever precautions you see as necessary
to take care of yourself and take care of your family.
But the point is it should be on you.
It should be on you not only as an individual citizen,
but it should be on you as a business owner or as a coach of a
baseball team or whatever it is you do. Let the people,
the people should make the decisions,
not these edicts from people that would love to keep us locked down forever.
All right, story, number three, I'm feeling very focused today. People,
can you feel it very focused? Uh, Mark Zuckerberg was at the big, uh,
the big, big tech hearing yesterday and, uh, you know,
to do a big tech hearing about big tech, uh,
for the Senate right before the election is, is kind of late. So yes,
it's a lot of theater, right? It's a lot of theater because nothing,
even if they talked to everybody yesterday and they, even if they own the earth,
Oh my God.
We found out the code that they wrote in the algorithm that is suppressing
things. And that is amplifying things and everything else it's like, well,
the damage has been done as far as this election, right? Like there's,
there's nothing that can be done in,
in these now four or five remaining days to fix the misinformation,
the suppression of use and all of those things.
This is all about maybe that something can be done in the future.
But I would say the idea of the hearing is good because getting Jack
and, and Zuckerberg and the Google guy,
getting these guys out there to talk does bring it forward in the
national conscious,
gets us hopefully to think about some of the issues and that kind of thing. But,
but don't be confused. It's not as if they're going to do something tomorrow,
that's going to save us from big tech. It ain't, it ain't happening.
And as I always say, big tech is not purely evil, right?
It's like a fire fire can do good stuff, warm up the house.
Fire can also burn down the house. And,
and I I'm here because of the pipes of YouTube. So, so I get it. I get it right.
Although you should join us@rubinreport.com because I do fully own that and can
communicate directly with you and we can build great communities for you.
Check out locals.com. Um, anyway, there's a,
there's an incredible exchange between John Thune,
Senator John Thune and Mark Zuckerberg.
So I'm going to read a little bit of the exchange because this just sort of sums
up the negligence of our media, the,
the way big tech treats us like children and sort of just the general state
of everything. So John Boone said to Zuckerberg,
the person that is in charge of election,
integrity and security at Facebook is a former Joe Biden staffer.
Is there someone closely associated with president Trump in the same role at
Facebook? He went on to say,
how do you all respond to the argument that there isn't sufficient balance in
terms of the political ideology or diversity in your companies?
And how do you deal with the lack of trust that creates amongst conservatives
to which Mark Zuckerberg replied? I think having balances valuable.
And while we, and we try to do that.dot dot,
I am not aware of the example of you say,
have someone in charge of this process who worked for Biden in the past.
So we can follow up on that. Well, it is in fact,
true that the person in charge of integrity and security at Facebook, uh,
that they are a former Biden staffer. Now, of course,
that shouldn't really surprise you. And by the way,
I don't necessarily begrudge people moving from say,
being a political staffer to having a,
another job or working at big tech and people move bounce around between
industries and all of those things. But in this case,
and especially in this highly polarized world that we live in, it's like,
if you don't think he's bringing some of those biases,
if you don't think some of those are kind of getting in,
getting into the system for the guy that's in charge of the election stuff at
Facebook, you know, then, then I'd like to,
I'd like to sell you something because of course it's happening. Right.
Of course it's happening. So the fact that Zuckerberg basically said,
he wasn't aware, kind of tells you everything. And this is often, you know what,
what's the famous line, the famous line, the buck stops with me. Right?
Meaning that if you're in charge of something,
you can't always blame everybody else. Oh no, no, no.
Is that low level staff or, Oh no, no, no. Is the janitor no. Oh,
part-time or did that at some point,
the buck stops with you and that's why being in the position that Zuckerberg is
in and being in the position that Jack Dorsey is in. These are not, um,
I would say enviable positions to be in there.
There were extraordinary problems that you can never fully solve
perhaps. And that in the case of, uh, Jack,
he probably just got himself in a lot of trouble by, by lying under oath.
Ted Cruz caught him, wa watch our video from yesterday.
If you're not sure what I'm talking about. Um, so look Zuckerberg saying,
he's not aware. It's like, alright, I don't know if you're lying or not.
If you're lying, then there's a problem. But if,
if you are in that just shows that you're not really in charge of your company,
like a decision. Well, who, who was in charge then? Like who made the decision?
If not you, the CEO,
I do believe that you've got to manage this entire unimaginably huge
organization. So then who was in charge? Was it a VP?
Was it someone in HR who made the decision? What was the thought process?
And now do we have evidence that this person is manipulating things again,
it's all too late for this election. So, so we shall see what, what happens.
All right, guys, I'm going to jump right now. I got, I got a crazy day. Uh,
I just shot a podcast with Glenn Beck. That'll be up over at the blaze, uh,
soon. Um, got a few other things we're shooting later this afternoon. Uh,
we are doing a direct message tomorrow. This is a five day a week week for us.
Uh, it's going to be a Q and a,
I suspect it'll be mostly about election stuff all with the Rubin report
community. So you can submit a question.
You can do it right now@rubinreport.com or download our iOS app or our Google
play app. Just search Rubin report, neither one of the stores, uh, QA tomorrow.
And then next week we're announcing our election coverage.
I'm going to be doing some live stuff in studio with the daily wire guys.
I'm going to be doing some stuff via the pipes,
via the wires with the blaze guys.
And then we're going to do at least one live stream the night of the election,
probably two. And then, uh,
when the election is not decided that night we'll be doing live streams every
day from then until perpetuity until the earth explodes,
which according to AOC is in about 11 years and six months.
So it's going to be a, it's going to be a hectic time. Uh, all right, guys,
I'll see you tomorrow. And if you want to submit questions,
run over to Rubin report.com. Have a great day, everybody.